okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have some
special guests on the channel and
welcome to the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you've watched two or more
of my lives and you do not subscribe we
have beef okay beef i'm like real tough
um
okay so also guys today's sponsor is
cooking with chris i tried for years to
lose 20 pounds i i did every diet i did
keto
literally every diet you could possibly
think of and it wasn't until i tried
cooking with chris that i actually
successfully lost the weight now what's
different about cooking with chris he
makes you a customized meal plan based
on foods you already eat so i was
already eating the foods i just wasn't
you know
anyways so that link is in the
description if you want to help support
the channel um make sure you do that
also if you guys want to support the
channel make sure you send a super chat
and we will read it and ask it to the
panel
okay so guys to start go around say your
name your age your relationship status
and where you're from
all right so i'm terrence i'm 36 i'm
from south london recently moved to
cannington and east and i'm in a
relationship
um my name is davidas i am 22 currently
living in east london and i am single
i'm parva i'm 20 from east london and
i'm very single
extremely single
my name's troy i'm 22
i'm single i'm living in east london
right now
my name is anaya i'm 25 i'm in a
relationship and i'm from brazil in new
york
my name is louisa i'm 22 i'm from south
london and i am single
okay guys so what have you heard about
the amber herd case have you guys heard
anything about it
i've only seen the live on tik tok when
he was given his testimony and stuff
like that that's about it
um so basically amber and johnny depp
were dating they were together okay
and um
amber came out a couple years ago and
had an article saying that she was in a
relationship that was abusive
and everybody in hollywood
knew that it was about him
and
so basically he was blacklisted from
hollywood remember like when we were
younger he was in pirates of the
caribbean and like all these movies they
just the best movies yeah and she didn't
take him to court over this like there
was nothing legally that happened but
everyone just believed her because you
know the the phrases kind of believe all
women right they take that this man's
career is ruined and now a couple years
later he's coming back and suing her
because it turns out he was actually the
one being abused
so um and this includes
um she threw a bottle at him and his
finger was severed
um she
there were accounts of him like hitting
her or her hitting him
and
just different accounts of like her
being very abusive towards him
so um it sort of begs the question
should we cancel somebody before all the
facts have come out and should we just
believe women when they accuse somebody
of assault or abuse
the situation seems a bit toxic
you know back and forth but
yeah i think definitely not you need to
know like what's going on because
like you said
people are more likely to believe the
woman
there's both sin they're abusing each
other and they're more likely to believe
the woman so just by cancelling the man
yeah straight up as well without any
facts
yeah
i feel like you should get like both
sides of the story not just the woman's
side obviously it favors the woman in
every type of way you're going against
the man and stuff but it's always better
to find
both sides of the story that's why i
think i think with like this generation
on the counseling part we're so quick to
cancel everyone
and i think that comes
um very much from our own insecurities
of always wanting to cancel people
um which is just very sad we don't know
all the facts and we still just decide
to cancel people like that
i agree i very strongly agree
um so why do you guys think
it's so common for if a girl comes
forward to just cancel the guy whether
or not the facts have come out
why do you think that is because it
doesn't seem like it's the other way
around it seems like it only happens
some women do it for their benefit i
guess like that would be
like money or something like that
because it's easy because it's easy for
example like if you're uh if you like if
a man makes certain amount of money and
he's like let's say famous and stuff
like that and a woman just
she doesn't know the man but she can
make up a real enough story to where the
judge can believe it she can extort him
for some amount of money before the
truth can come out if she's got all her
facts straight and stuff like that
without with the correct backstory so
some people do like that for like money
and stuff like that sort of thing
like why do you think that is as a
society why do we just believe
women i think um
i think typically
women i think typically women are um
more preyed on by men
um or at least in a woman's lifetime
and they would have experienced
harassment in comparison to men so it's
easier for people to believe a woman
whenever she whenever she
makes these claims because
just generally speaking
at least in my personal experience
majority if not 100 of the women i've
women i know have at least at some point
in their lifetime experience harassment
by males whereas none of the men i know
have experienced it which is why i
believe it's easier
to um to believe a woman without the
facts even though it's not right to do
so
yeah
what do you guys think
i mean like
it's like judging a book by its title
really you haven't read the whole story
to really understand what's going on so
just going off the back i feel like
maybe we need to actually learn to
assess things properly before we jump to
conclusions because you never know that
woman generally could be lying on
someone's name for her own benefit so
yeah it is a bit it was a bit toxic that
that situation so i'm just curious to
the girls have you ever had a girl that
you know tell you that she'd been
assaulted
oh yeah 100
100 yeah dude do you question it or do
you automatically believe her i never
question the victim i try to not but i
will ask questions
um if she's comfortable answering those
questions
um
but i think it's important to at least
start off by believing the victim
because they need to be comfortable
enough to tell you
and there's a lot of like emotion
attached to it as well it's not just
like them you know telling the story
there's a lot of like ptsd emotion and
things that are going with it
yeah i've had to fight a person once
yeah but i've seen that thing happen
like i've seen that yeah yeah
yeah it was um it was one of my friends
and stuff like that she had a
guy over i guess and
yeah one thing led to another he was a
bit there i heard something that i
shouldn't have heard i walked in and
this guy is doing my masalini's next to
you know i busted his head through the
window so
yeah
make sure you guys bring the mic to your
mouth if you're going to talk just
there's some comments about it um
what do you think
so it's interesting though because we
say like
we can't just believe all women but we
kind of do as girls
you know like if a girl comes to you and
says something like that that's kind of
our immediate gut reaction
and it's tough because i feel like
celebrity situations kind of model real
life you know what i mean like like
they're kind of examples of what's going
on in like our real lives but like when
it hits the forefront that's when you
have an example of it
i think
i think that's because as women
we've experienced similar things
so it's hard not to believe someone
coming out and saying these things
because it's unfortunately so common
so yeah so me being
a victim of domestic abuse um
i feel like for me to tell someone was
very hard i wouldn't tell anybody so if
somebody comes up to you and actually
talks about it then i would actually
believe them because it's not just like
yeah a topic you just you know tell
anyone yeah so yeah
um
on the question that you asked i think
why you would
um
believe the woman first is because
obviously if you see a man
saying that he's getting beat up by his
girlfriend that's
it's
it happens but it's rare like
men are seen as stronger than women
so it's like
when a man's
saying he's getting abused by his
girlfriend or and the girlfriend saying
you're more likely to believe the girl
because
men are seen to be bigger stronger it's
like it's
it's
unlikely that a girl is gonna beat up
their boyfriend but it does happen so
yeah that's why i think women are
believed you know what's interesting
i've heard more men tell me like in
person my personal life that they've
been victims of domestic assault than
women
yeah like because a lot of guys don't
report it because they don't feel
comfortable because you're getting beat
up by a girl
so is that also like another problem
like you know i'm fine takes a whole new
meaning for the guy versus you know i
mean because when a girl says i'm fine
like you gotta go and you gotta make
sure that she's really fine because
she's never fine but like when when a
guy says it's like so holding a
different meaning
yeah like she was just saying it's it
was hard for like you to come out and
speak about it
i think as a man it may be even be
harder because
um
like
people could laugh at you like if you're
a woman you get a bit more sympathy i
think but if your mind is going to be
even harder like
if you're going through that sort of
thing yeah you have to be quite quite
strong and brazilian yeah it's going to
happen because because generally
speaking like if a man comes out saying
oh my wife always like most guys
responses and even some of the females
are listening stop being a [ __ ] like
why why are you being a [ __ ] you know i
mean that's
yeah like you know what i mean like oh
yo yo you're the man of the house why
are you not too why are you not telling
her what you know i mean it's just
that's
what it's even in the audio tape with um
amber hud and johnny depp where he
secretly recorded her confessing to her
to assaulting him she was calling him a
[ __ ] yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah i mean that's a lot of
respect as well 100 for your
relationship to get into that kind of
stage where
a lot is going on like that so yeah do
you think that if a girl hits a guy he
can hit her back
i don't think so i don't think equality
last time last i checked human wanted
equality so that's a very
you could um pin her down
like yo yeah don't try it yeah you can't
you know what i mean but there's other
ways around it don't need to now give
her a black eye or something because
yeah i feel like you can do other i feel
like things i feel like um
a man shouldn't
just because of the the potential damage
it could cause you know and he could
then go into a rage but he should
he should like he said pin her down or
you know stand grounds you know what i
mean yeah not to just take cause because
devil's advocate what happened to that
guy in miami when he didn't hit her back
the guy in miami with the only fans
model
oh the one was to go stop he died
right because she stopped him
what okay you don't hear about that no
because
they'll stab them today
yeah there's no way
that's a bit mad how old is that even
and you know what's interesting in court
like um
men get four times the sentencing for
the same crime
oh wow yeah than women
so it's like even if they do get
convicted like girls aren't really sent
to jail over this stuff it's really not
taken like the same why do you guys
think that is
i think
similar to what i said earlier like they
get more sympathy because they're seen
as more
fragile fragile yeah like feminine you
know girls girls aren't seen as like
people who yeah like your men can be
seen as evil aggressive like but then
when women are doing the same thing
it's
you it's unexpected so like it's not as
believable when it does happen
that's crazy i was gonna say so like you
said that obviously like if if a woman
hits a man you really shouldn't like you
know him but like where would you just
draw the line because for example like
hitting is one thing yeah but like if
you see a woman like like you said like
the man that died right it's a woman's
coming at you with a knife would you
feel like that's a a valuable reason for
you to actually take
that's right
you got a whole weapon like she's got a
whole weapon like they're you're
fighting for your life at that point
she's put you in a position where you
might have to actually knock her out
yeah
jeremy
yeah i think that if she hits you you
should be able to hit her back because i
think that women would maybe take it a
little bit more seriously before you hit
a guy
like i just think girls like today they
have no consequence they can they can do
damn near anything there's like no
consequence
but a guy he gets sent to like jail or
prison over that stuff yeah i get what
you're saying but
if a woman slaps a man and then a man
slaps a woman
the guy is more likely to be stronger
and he's going to do more damage
what are you gaining from slapping her
back like yeah but it's like she
shouldn't have been slapping him in the
first place that's what i'm saying it
does take a lot for like a woman to
actually grab that courage and slap a
man because i guess it depends on the
way it's like depends it does depend on
the woman but it also depends on the
situation as well
okay
like troy said i think if you're able to
leave leave
why are you fighting back but if it's
life or death then obviously you have to
hit back believe
i just think if
i put this do you okay so if it's about
strength right
do you think that a weaker if a weaker
guy hits a jacked guy
that the jack guy can't hit him back
skinny skinny that's a skinny on a
muscle man that's that's just that's
just a fight i would like to see i'm not
gonna lie like let's say let's say he's
just feeling ballsy okay and he he hits
the like the most jacked guy in the room
hey listen nominations to you my brother
live long i hope you survive i promise
you yeah like i'm just
there's no it would be so funny because
like the jack guy would probably just
pick him up and throw just just flip him
just like yeah
but the same way i don't think a jack
guy would would actively go into a
fight with somebody who who he sees to
be weaker than him unless he's on
steroids
yeah yeah if we're talking like if we're
talking generally
a guy who knows he can definitely you
know well because he has the consequence
right
but women don't have the consequences
because one the law isn't holding them
accountable
and two
the um
like guys think they can't hit them back
yeah that's true
so how do we how do we hold women
accountable then so this doesn't happen
in the future like what do you think we
could do to change things like this
that's i think that's probably why she
was
uh had more motivation or courage to do
it because she knew the consequence she
wasn't she didn't think she would get
caught yeah she thinks are
me hitting this guy like no one's going
to believe him
yeah excuse me
that's given her more
um
you know more energy to do it yeah
whereas if i think if there was
if they make like a statement now or
they make um an example of her then
women in the future are gonna be like oh
no they're gonna be more scared to like
beat up their vulnerable boyfriends or
whatever i think harsher sentences or
equal signs yeah i was going to say yeah
yeah exactly
not even i'm really the law's corrupt
though this is yeah it is
but i was gonna say i'm really happy he
came out and did it even though it's
like several years later yeah because it
shows them he he's like a role model to
so many people yeah so it shows that you
can be vulnerable you can be a man like
do you think for a girl
if a girl damages a guy's character so
if a girl goes around saying that he did
something doesn't press charges do you
think the guy
do you think she should be able to be
punished like criminally for that 100
once you're accused of something even if
you're found innocent that will stick if
he says the same thing back he's they're
either going to say he's just doing it
to be petty
do you know what i mean or they're just
not going to believe it you know what
i'm trying to say yeah
yeah i feel like that she needs to be
held accountable if she does that
isn't that illegal to begin with
well she i don't think she guys correct
me in the chat if i'm wrong but i don't
think she legally like tried to
like i don't think she took him to court
over it so um i think it would be
illegal if she took him to court but she
just basically put out an article that
was very like one-sided and just said
that like it was so abusive and then he
it tarnished his career in hollywood
because especially a couple years ago it
very much was just believe all women
like remember that like it was that was
everywhere
and so
you know that that just like ruined his
career
let me see if they am i right in the
chat i wanted to see
yeah so do you think um like if someone
does that on like a campus they should
be able to sue like the same thing
well like universities like spreading
rumors in camp
you notice they're like rumors
honestly yeah because like in in high
school like we've all spread i've spread
rumors in high school when i was younger
i'm not gonna like you i'm guilty i've
been that guy
we're not gonna we're not gonna we're
not gonna get we're not gonna get we're
not gonna get into it yeah but i've i've
had rumor spread about me and then you
just carried on to college and stuff
like we do that type of job i don't
think it would be like
anything serious like anything that you
could take legal action upon like oh
this guy
like it's kind of like university oh
this like it's a small university that
we have in new york right and if someone
has sex with someone
it's instant because it's such a small
campus so like the rumor the world gets
around quickly but i just like i don't
think they they should be like legally
but i think it does exactly exactly you
know what i mean if it takes away
opportunities from you and yeah biggest
opportunities then you're you should be
that's a big roommate you're spreading
it
yeah that's what i'm saying like but
like in most part like what what would
take your chances away from you like
unless it's unless like your lecturers
hear about like you doing some crazy
stuff the night before yeah yeah
if it's like involving like drugs and
your career and stuff like that because
athletes and drugs that kind of stuff
yeah all the time so it is is a bit of
what are you spreading type thing that
will have an effect on someone
have you guys ever
been in a situation where somebody
accused someone of someone and you
didn't really believe them like it
doesn't have to be a close friend but
just someone you knew
yeah
yeah
well i'll see you as well what what like
what happened
um it was a friend of mine not a friend
of mine a mutual friend of mine um who
said that she was pregnant
um and as a mutual friend
um i told my friend to ask her like yo
show us the test so we can help you
she refuses to show us the test
for weeks like six weeks eight weeks we
say we'll come to the doctor's with you
he's like no i want no one there so we
show up the doctor there's no
appointment
and so after like five months we're like
was this true she's like no oh my god so
what was that
but we had to still feel sorry for her
because to go to that length
to do that
it takes a lot
so yeah
yeah wait you still felt sorry for her i
i felt sorry for her because you have to
be at a very low point in your life to
say first of all accuse this boy of
making you pregnant because he's on the
other side like show me the test as a
father he should be able to see the test
i just think you're like a bad person
you are but
you feel sorry for someone i don't feel
sorry for that
so would you what would you you're just
such a nice person you're such a nice
person man
i mean
like if i came to you and i was like oh
my gosh i'm pregnant
what would your first initial like
reaction be how far along are you
i would say
well
when did it happen my first initial
reaction to people i know is to believe
them i don't i don't naturally just
think people are crazy
yeah you know then it's like you would
have you have to kind of but poke at
that person to kind of know
yeah yeah i mean it's it's more like
you don't always know the character of
people so you ask like questions right
how far along are you who's the dad and
if everything like lines up you kind of
yeah you naturally believe people
but
that's not something to really lie about
being pregnant why would you lie about
that especially when you tell the person
that you think is the father of the baby
because that puts him in a very
vulnerable position i can ruin a man as
well exactly because then he's got to
tell his his family
like all of this like
and then if it's not even true then you
you've had all that stress for no reason
literally
do you think that
men should be able to take a woman to
court for that for lying absolutely
pregnant absolutely absolutely yeah
no because because you're looking to
know because you've got cause you've got
to look at it you can look at it this
way right
she just told me that she's pregnant
right cool so now i've got to go and
like you said tell my family and then
they're going to have a go at me and
then their family gonna go and they're
gonna want it and you know how like some
old old uh old testament families like
oh i want to see a test i want to see
this i want to meet the girls parents
and stuff like that and then you go
through all that length through all that
trouble to
ideally
basically ruin the man's life
and then
all of that just to find out that she's
not really pregnant absolutely yeah
absolutely you should be able to take it
to court
yeah i mean it does play a big role
that's a whole lot because you gotta you
gotta look at it like this right let's
say you let's say for example you say
you're pregnant to me and i and i'm the
dad right yeah cool i go away and i do
whatever i gotta do now i dropped out of
university because right now i've got
work and supplies now i've got a job and
i mean and then you come and find out
you know you know i mean about life
stuff like that no way
it's big it's too much of a big impact
to to carry that into someone else's
life not just your own that is
big
yeah do you what about if a girl had to
go to like do you think she should be
able to go to jail for that
i think i mean it's jail's a bit much
still alive
maybe he's not here okay
like he's still alive what what if the
guy is what if the guy he gets like mad
depressed he ends up like killing
himself and stuff because because you
made some mad rumor like
emotional damage yeah emotional damage
then she should be held accountable
because you've like you basically killed
the same time
i mean yeah
how much i think that there's gonna be
consequences they can't just be there
make up a wild rumor and like ruin
someone's life
what if
he commits suicide after her just sent
like texting and saying i'm pregnant
it's your baby she should still go to
jail for one message no no okay
i just think there has to be some level
of accountability because i just think
the way i look at society is like
if you take away the consequences for
anything there are shitty people that
are going to abuse it
and i just think these days
we've taken away a lot of the
consequence for women with stuff like
believe all women with stuff like
even like the in court you know and even
just our society naturally
empathizing with women and you know
taking them at face value yeah but i
feel like you can't do that too much
because you're then you're putting rules
and laws on every single little thing
like there'll be a lot there'll be a law
fir for everything like you can't say
this you can't do that and then people
be restricted yeah then you've got no
freedom i'm not i'm not talking about
that i'm talking about just i'm just
talking about women getting equal
sentencing for the same crime
yeah or i'm talking about like even in
this conversation
most people didn't agree with me when i
said you should be able to hit a woman
back
i i didn't i refuse to answer that
because no comment is the best comment
you know what i'm saying
i was smack a [ __ ] if she got knife yo
then it's different but i think like
troy said if she slaps you then why
would you slap her back like pin her
down let her know you're the man yeah
just restrict her
[ __ ] before she hits me
no you can't try again you know what i
mean it's not a thing where you need to
now go we had damager
we had a talk about a similar thing what
was it of course ago when we talked
about like oh
you shouldn't be able to like you
shouldn't have to hit a woman yet but
you you need to go to as a man you need
to go to a certain length here to where
she needs to understand that no matter
how strong she thinks she is she will
get put down and you know i mean like
so if you're not gonna if you're not
gonna hit the woman back even if you
grab her wrist and
or like or if you're gonna stay yeah you
know what i mean like
i don't know just to hit a woman i mean
you're going to do some damage or at
least if i'm if i'm if it's me
and if i respond
this normally happens
in like a fresh relationship right it's
like when a woman starts smiling out and
starts like going to like try to abuse
the man like hit him or whatever right
and the guy obviously doesn't do
anything but like let her know that
she's not gonna do it and then she goes
like oh my god he hit me he done this he
done that and she will go through some
women will be crazy enough to actually
hit themselves making it look like the
man done it and then report it to the
law yeah but maybe there's maybe she's
going through her own like
emotional why take it out on the guy
though
yeah maybe there's an issue there not
just like her towards a guy maybe okay
but would you say that if the roles were
reversed
if a dude did that to a woman if
a dude did that
and it's just it's just funny because
that's our and i think it's like natural
in us yeah like like when a guy does
something it's just not as empathized
but the women when women a woman does
something it's like well what about her
mental state what about what she was
going through
what about us
who cares are we going through men out
there as well
don't get twisted but there are like
majority of females are more emotional
would you say that like a lot of the
females are like
emotion guided
so like to to different likes situations
and stuff
it just depends on the situation
yeah it just depends on the situation
because if it's a situation where it's
now affecting me mentally then we have a
problem
whereas like if i'm if i'm okay with it
and i can deal with it then i'm all
right type thing because normally um
because normally the like it's been i
don't know where it's been said but like
like when it's like hard decisions not
necessarily like buying a house but like
men tend to be more saints and like in
and like more composed
whereas like women are like more like
but if the emotion is maybe we just
think then that's what we're going to go
with the stuff as well
like not just the decision like what
else could affect the decision like what
more is there to it like you could buy a
house but i'm thinking like is the train
station there like can i get to college
can i go to work
there's just so much more to the
decision i feel like
right yeah that's a bit generalizing
though i feel like yeah like
any man could think like that as well
any woman
but yeah what are you saying
we all
we are we naturally or at least we
develop
responding with emotion and then there
are those of us who develop trying to
suppress that and responding with logic
but majority of time we all respond at
least we i would say we respond with
emotion first
in
most situations i think everyone like
male to females yeah 100 oh i don't
women are chemically different every
single day
like depending on where we're at in our
cycle like before before that's like why
we get super irritable before a period
so i think men like naturally or more
he's had
enough like you don't understand
second day that
first day is like the come on is cool
the second day the second day oh my
like god just think that like women come
more from a place like and i'm a pretty
logical girl but like yeah i feel like
even i feel like the most logical girls
we acknowledge that we're emotional like
emotional beings and we kind of look to
men to be more logical
you know you've never noticed a
difference in the emotions between men
and women during the the time of the
month women have like more mood swings
no just in general like women because
you said you think it's equal and i'm
just shocked because no i meant i feel
like we equally in situations
equally would naturally respond
emotionally not all the time but i feel
like it's i feel like i think you're an
emotional male
oh yeah
yeah definitely
as in being in touch with my emotions
yeah yeah
yeah i'm not
sometimes it's so especially like
relationships it's so hard to
communicate with you guys and come to an
agreement because
y'all don't want to be vulnerable i'm
not talking like oh generally so it
makes it harder
like we'll we'll have a whole
we'll talk for like 30 minutes and
you'll be like cool why
and i'm sat here explaining to you why
yeah i don't know
i know you're thinking more than you're
saying you have to put it on the table
nah but you know what it is you gotta
you gotta understand right when you're
in a relationship with like
uh together right and let's say you you
have a disagreement about it right a man
will only go to like a certain level we
will go and we'll tell you the logic
side of it will tell you the facts and
stuff like that your emotions take over
to a point where we just want to leave
we just don't want to continue with the
conversation because like we're not no
man has ever won an argument with a
woman like
if he's one no but like you know but you
know i mean that you know what i mean
what i mean it's like
no matter if you think you won you
haven't won you know what i'm trying to
say like i guess like for example the
way i feel if like if i've had an
argument ago it's like
i'll be done it's not about winning the
argument it's about coming to an
agreement either you agree to disagree
or come to an agreement if you're wrong
if you're wrong
but the thing is
in a healthy relationship you don't
argue to win
but but the thing is like
you say you want emotional availability
but women aren't attracted to that i was
done i was going to say i was going to
say that i was going to say that just
shifted because
when when a guy when a guy
when a guy shows a vulnerability yeah
girls think oh they want a guy who like
cares in that but when it when they show
a bit of like sensitivity and stuff then
they get turned off like they're like
they don't like that but who said that
like
they've studied this like when men
when men cry when men cry in front of
women the woman loses respect for him
and it's not and and i would be in you
know what here's have you ever dated an
[ __ ]
go that's what i mean
wait so you dated an [ __ ] right so
you're attracted you're not attracted to
emotional availability that's what i
wanted i wanted someone to be no but no
you didn't because that's who you were
sleeping with
that's what you think you want but it's
not what you actually want go ahead yeah
like go gosh yeah
they like they like bad boys like when
the guys they say oh they want a nice
guy does all of this like and then when
that guy comes around they're like oh
whatever then they're like well
personally
it's literally it's literally you know
what it is it's literally the it's
literally the
nice guy's finished last theory yeah
because you know what it is yeah girls
will say
the girls will say listen i want a guy
that's like let's say the provider that
can take care of me that's nice caring
compassionate emote like emotionally
available and stuff yeah but when that
guy comes around like you said yeah it's
like they look they took one look at him
they give him like
one two maybe three dates if you're
lucky yeah but if you show that that
you're there for her like emotion and
stuff like that that's not attractive to
the woman who's the woman the woman and
i've said it's an older podcast
me i'm a very emotional person like i
feel like if you can now connect to me
on that level then i'm good because
clear communication and expressing
yourself to me allows me to express me
to you type thing i don't feel like
not like at the start when your first
like day and that's like deep like when
you're in when you've known each other
for a couple years maybe
not a couple years exactly like this is
yeah i need to have that conversation
with you can you open up exactly because
are you able to open up because a lot of
men they get taught from their mothers
and family to not be emotional to not
talk about their emotions to be a man to
be strong you know all of that so that's
why i feel like a lot of men also have
problems communicating their feelings
because they're not used to it
how long do you guys think that you
should be seeing a girl before you like
start to open up emotionally like i
think i should do it as little as
possible to be honest because because
it's bad advice like you know i'm
telling you like i think you guys come
at it with like a good a good heart
but like
you're chemically less attracted to men
that are vulnerable
because like
and it's not it's not a nice reality but
this is this is how i know it every time
i ask girls have you dated an [ __ ]
they always say yes
they always say yes back that a second
cause you said like why would you keep
on sleeping with that person i think for
a couple weeks you still have that hope
that he might open up someday but you
end up leaving you do but that's the
reason you're not in a relationship with
that [ __ ] you're just dating him well
did he want to be in a relationship the
[ __ ]
probably not no comment yeah that's
that's what i'm saying
but it's always really good
and this is this is what i'm saying like
like in the reason the reason there's
like biological reasons that we feel the
way we feel and we can't just undo them
so the reason is because the same traits
that make the guy the hero also make him
the villain
so like like the guy that's the
protector provider like he he he has to
be you know aggressive on some level he
has to be able able to protect you
and emotionally in control you don't see
superman crying like
like in a movie you see hulk when he
like just goes all the way back to human
just for his girl
mm-hmm
so what would you say um
about i was just fictional about
leonidas to his queen
in 300.
looking to her for sort of approval
before his next action before kicking
the messenger down the pit i mean i
think you can always find exceptions to
the rule but that doesn't make it the
rule fair enough like just because you
can name one example doesn't know like
and it's just like i just think we
confuse men and it makes them more like
feminine
and it's we're not attracted to it it's
not fun like i don't enjoy being
attracted to [ __ ] but i i like
i don't i don't enjoy it but like you
can't
admit you can't deny that it's there you
know what i mean
for me like being emotionally available
as a guy means also like sp or
specifically means you can communicate
with me it's not just about like crying
or you know breaking down or anything
like that it's just can you tell me how
you're feeling and i'm not talking about
like oh i'm so sad i mean like
openly communicate with me what's going
right what's going wrong like just talk
to me yeah because a lot of guys when
you ask them like what's going on
they're like i'm good yes
what does what does i'm good means it's
exactly the same it's exactly the same
as i'm fine when you're not fine oh but
guys do that too yeah no that's why
that's what i'm saying
i'm good it's exactly the same as when
you go say i'm fine when you don't when
you're not actually fine that's
basically what it is but we we as guys
just don't like the better we say we're
fine yeah and then we come back and
we're like okay this is what's actually
going on you guys never come back we'll
ask you ten times like what's going on
and yeah
and then you'll feel like we're
pestering you and then it becomes an
issue
you kind of have to drag them
that's that's why but but that's why
like like she said that like yo you're
like not more attracted to the [ __ ]
in it because like if we start opening
up like maybe not to you or whatever
like you're maybe like one in a million
but like
if we start opening up to you like after
we say like oh i'm good and i come back
and i tell you what's actually happening
you'll lose respect for me you'll lose
that outside of them that's it
i wanted you to answer me exactly i mean
i understand here and there but i've
been in a relationship where a guy told
me everything that was bothering him and
i was going nuts
like i don't i don't want to hear every
single problem you have like you know
you're not you're their therapist
and and this is but we have to be yours
as guys we have to stop no no no that's
a double that's the double because
listen you don't want to be our
therapist no no no you don't want to be
you don't want to be our therapist but
we we
have been you know you don't want to be
our therapist yeah but we as guys have
been but like not even qualified to do
but where's your therapist because when
when you talk we listen we listen good
to every little thing
what's really really to me today
but i'm not gonna lie i feel like women
we don't tell
the guys everything either like we don't
tell them everything so i feel like
there has to be a balance
like i want to know about your life i
want to know what's going on and you do
the same but like there's the
communication part of it
just be open but you know don't tell me
everything
but do you see how confusing that is for
guys because you're like tell me
something but don't tell me everything
like
where is the line where is your life
like where is your guys's line
like tell me about the day cool i woke
up went to work come back is that like
is that the line is that roughly where
the line is like because that's what it
feels like it's like say something
happened and it made you feel some type
of way that's what i want to know
because that's what is has stuck with
you throughout the day
oh i woke up i brushed my teeth i knew
that no but a lot of guys a lot of guys
growing up not being not knowing how to
communicate with their emotions so when
they're in when they're adults in their
relationships they don't even know where
to start so if somebody i'm literally
that guy how's your day that's okay
like do you know what i mean i'm cool
like how are you i'm cool just because i
won't even know where to start if i'm to
express whatever it is i'm going through
do you know what i'm trying to say i
feel like from their own experience as
well
when they have
like opened up or
like told them about the whole day or
whatever yeah it hasn't worked for them
yeah what's worked for them is like yeah
nothing i'm cool i'm good like that's
worked for them so yeah
yeah but wouldn't you want like a person
that you're able to actually talk to how
you feel yeah family members
other guys but like in a woman
no we don't we don't
well i just think like when you're when
you're asking guys to do that you're
asking them to be more feminine
inerrantly and like in the long run
you're not going to be attracted to that
i think i think you guys can relate to
that but if a guy if i love someone or i
care about someone
what's bothering them is bothering me
so if they're in a bad mood it's going
to affect me either way so i want to
know what it is so we can figure it out
and that's when
i'm sorry it's [ __ ] up because men
don't open up and then we're just
sitting there like
in a bad mood bad energy bad vibes well
i need you to be vulnerable i need to
tell me what's going on because it's
affecting me now as well and us
as a team
yeah but like you know what yeah i found
something else to flip on you like you
know when you're you know when you're
the one that's upset but then they
started they flipped on you like why she
gets upset with you for being upset with
yeah like
like what
how does that work
like like dude they would be like two
guys baby what's wrong nah i'm good in
it cool so they walk away they don't
fight they don't come back here they
come back why are you always upset like
they come here
what i swear like hold on that's the
thing because if we ask you what's going
on and you're like i'm fine i'm good
whatever that's why we get annoyed
because yeah exactly
but i'm the one that's upset why are you
flipping but i think the real problem is
initially the guy's not in control of
his emotions
like i don't think it's the i think if
he was just in control of his emotions
to start
and if he like and if he can give you
one specific thing to like like work on
that's one thing but it's when the guy's
being all emotional and like having a
hissy fit and you're like what the
is there an issue
but
i'm gonna read guys there's two super
chats but one isn't loading i'm sorry
also all super chats are going towards a
second camera um i'd really like to get
it
um next month so you get paid on youtube
monthly so all the super chats you guys
send this month i'm gonna get next month
so hopefully i need to raise like 200
more dollars
um help her out guys yeah she's doing
great she's doing great
okay so um one super chat was let me
find it
um okay ask how many times per week can
a man cry
my negative one
how many how many times a week can your
man cry
i think it depends like say first
exactly imagine he's lost someone
important to him like cry as much as you
want you have to get it out
but if it's like like you said like just
give us a block just give us a blunt
honest number
but what's more attractive a man that
can like hold it together and be strong
or a man that's like blubbering on the
floor like crying for like weeks being
vulnerable and crying foreign
no listen like i said it depends the
situation if it comes home and he's like
so you annoyed me at work and started
like
oh that's an ick yeah
yeah for two three weeks straight
every single day you're you're you're
it's fine but you're actually doing the
same thing for two years yeah but you're
a girl so like but you're equally you're
equally attracted but she's i'm sorry
you want to screw him the same no but i
mean there's a way to deal with that
because if i i'm there for you so i'm
gonna help you get up yes a long time
yeah i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
step in now because i've allowed you one
two weeks all right but no no we need to
work on this let's let's
even if i if if i was a girl i even i'd
be like listen bro like you need to fix
up like that
when you're tired
you had your time to move like you had
your time to like you know cry and yeah
you're still going you know what i mean
we're going to learn how to deal with
this because there's no way i'm going to
watch someone cry
no like every person obviously every
person here has like
different ways of dealing with it like
whether that's crying for weeks on end
or kind of like getting back to work
because everyone's doing it but like
there's a certain time where it's like
yo like like you're living like
the person's gonna be loved and
remembered you're gonna go
put flowers in the grave and light a
candle and you know just chill there and
talk to that grave you know what i mean
but like life goes on like you gotta
like move past that no matter obviously
it's gonna be hard but yeah deal with it
like the way you wanna do it i don't
think there's i don't think there's a
time limit on that like for example my
friend
lost his mom um he lost his dad when he
was much younger when he was a child and
then he lost his mom and he's his only
only child like if he wanted to cry for
a whole year i get it because that was
the only person you were close to like
he has family like uncles and aunties
and stuff yeah but like we get it yeah
well i mean
like
hey there's a difference
i think girls get it i think girls get
it but we're just not attracted to it
yeah i was gonna say your question was
are you are you more attracted to
someone who's going to deal with it
straight away start going gym like
like deal with it that way or
it's gonna
okay like cry a little bit
but then you're not gonna be attracted
to someone that's you're gonna be more
attracted to someone who's like wow
they're going out there yeah they're
doing like i don't know like charity
marathons for whatever or they're like
they're doing something active you know
to like get over it making sure that
they're still gonna like she said okay
and how you're dealing with it she's
like i get that but she's saying what's
more attractive
i think
i'll be better i think i think it
depends i think if you say
i think if you're saying that
i'm sorry i think if you're saying like
yo you're good because i think
no i think it depends on if
crying every day every day for however
however long is fine
if you're not moping about if you're
still proactive so if you're still
proactive he's still doing what he needs
to do but every now and again
you know he'll catch himself thinking
about the person he lost and he cries
that's perfectly fine but if he's just
doing nothing and dedicating his you
know every waking hour to just crying
and not yeah being motivated and i can
completely understand that you know that
being a turn-off but i feel like i'm not
a woman but i feel like a woman can
still find a guy attractive if he's
crying every day but still showing her
masculine yeah yeah i just
i think
and this is bad this is bad but it's
just honestly i think a woman can
understand yeah but i don't think a girl
really is going to want to screw you
after she's seen you crying i just don't
think we're turned down bring them bring
them down a bit as well if they're
trying to always cheer you up yeah it's
going to bring you down as well a little
bit yeah and like it's not it's not fun
i don't enjoy this it's just i just
think it's how we're wired like we want
we want the guy like the the men i
respect the most in my life like when i
think of them they don't cry yeah like
my dad i've seen him cry like twice
there's no one i respect more than my
dad
and every time like i've seen him yeah
twice in my life
and it's much better to like i think
have like strong masculine presence and
then occasionally like when you if that
happens now and then it's like rather
than someone that's blubbering like or
every every time something goes wrong
they're blubbering because how am i
supposed to trust you if you're like
in your feminine and like every time
something goes wrong
i guess it depends it depends on the
frequency yeah yeah if
if it's all the time it's a bit
i feel like for that sort of reason as
well that's why like a lot of men
they go there's a lot more men that um
commit suicide than females yeah i think
it's it's got a lot to do with that as
well because they don't want to see
be seen vulnerable by their partner or
they don't want to
show emotions so
they let it build up by trying to be
active or do whatever rather than just
let out yeah it builds up mentally and
then they end up like killing themself
or you know being depressed or like
gets worse
so i feel like women women can
level out they can cry whether they
could talk talk or whatever about their
problems
and i feel like it can get dealt with
better
because um
they're allowed to they're allowed to by
society basically so
yeah well i think i think men should be
able to like cry and be emotional i just
think they should be able to they should
do it to other men
like that's the worst
that that's that's even worse
you can't you can call it the worst but
it's honest like i'm just being honest
like your girl is not going to respect
you like every study that's ever studied
this
ever
has has has come to the conclusion that
if the girl
if if the guy cries in front of the girl
she does not respect you the same and so
like i could lie to like i could lie to
you and say oh and like pretend i'm
different
and but i'm like being honest like i i
don't think it's wise to cry in front of
your girl all the time like she's not i
mean
like i don't know like how often you
guys cry
oh yeah let me know actually i've not
cried in a minute
i've not cried in a minute there's
nothing there no no you actually
like the last time i've cried i remember
specifically that was when my great
grandma passed away but the way i cried
was like it was one of those things
where i walked in here and i saw her
like in the casket and stuff like that
and then i just stared for a minute and
then i didn't like
cry but it was automatic like my tears
just started pouring out so i'm just
there with the most straightest face and
like just
yeah it's like it's like you know when
you're trying to hold like you'd be
trying to be gangster be like
but it's just
automatic
you know
yeah
and that was like
six years ago
um i'm gonna read the super chats really
quick okay
um
my favorite donut sentience
fifty dollars come on girl come on my
god
hey
he's back
okay um again guys all of these super
chats are going towards another camera
i'm trying to get
angle here angle here if we raise
five hundred dollars during this stream
i think i wanna i'm sorry i'm
ballparking i don't know the exact
number
but it's like around five hundred
dollars i'm trying to get before the end
of the month so we can afford another
camera okay so
um ladies stop trying to change men into
women we don't think or act like you we
can't afford to open up our insecurities
to women in fear of having women lose
interest since we do not know what their
threshold is pressure is made for
shoulders not hips you guys think
ladies stop trying to change men into
women we don't think or act like you we
can't afford to open up our insecurities
to women in fear of having women lose
interest since we don't know what your
threshold is pressure is made for
shoulders not hips
so basically they can't open up because
every
woman has a different threshold for what
she deems acceptable and how are they
supposed to know well then i guess um
the guy has to find out what her
threshold is be smart about it but find
it out and um
yeah like if you if you really love the
girl and she loves you she's gonna
understand like with me i'd rather have
a guy open up to me and let me know
what's going on than have me being
annoyed at you now that you're not
telling me because i'll be annoyed i'll
be like bro why why why aren't you
telling me that american is coming out
right now
that new york is coming yeah no
seriously though like if i'm asking you
like you're sitting down i'm here with
you i'm like i can see on your face that
you're annoyed and i'm like what's going
[Applause]
so would you rather him control his
emotions in the first place and like
come to you and say like i don't accept
that behavior from you
um like like we can't this isn't going
to work if you keep doing this
and like instead of like having an
editing thing for me for me when i ask
i'm like what's wrong he can literally
just be like listen i didn't have a good
day but i don't want to talk about it
tell me that but don't just say i'm good
tell me i don't want to talk about it i
respect that mm-hmm i'll leave you at
that that's why
that's fine with me we can talk about
another time i can bring it up again
maybe but if you tell me you don't want
to talk about it me personally i respect
that well i just you told me it just
sounds like the it sounds like the
initial problem is like him not being
able to control his emotions to start
and like kind of copying an attitude
with you for what seems like no reason
and also how he said like the comments
said um changing men and to women
we're not gonna do that i love our
differences i think that's what makes a
relationship very special the
differences but i think like you said
just communicating
yeah and clear ground like you're doing
that you're feeling like this all right
cool
i mean i don't saw like stuff i don't
feel like a guy crying can be deemed as
a woman expecting a guy to cry
as a guy being emotional because crying
is
emotional do you know what i mean yeah
but it's not it's not it's not it's not
a trait that only women should share or
have or carry you know men crying isn't
feminine if that makes sense well i
think crying is feminine because it's
more emotional
so so like i can i can do masculine
things
like no guys i see no sad conversations
um i can do masculine things right but
that that's me doing a masculine thing
right like that's doing something that's
feminine okay for us like so the
consensus is crying is a feminine thing
yeah
crying's more feminine it's more
emotional
i don't know i don't know if i agree
what about what i've cried
okay so for girls if a girl's like
blubbering right
i guess it depends on the type of crying
because i've cried in front of my um
partners at various times but i've never
been they've never looked i don't know
their true feelings but
they've never sort of lost respect for
me because
it could be like they know what i'm like
i'm very masculine i'm also very i'm in
touch my emotional side
and
me crying in front of you and you are
not going to lose respect for it it just
won't happen but i'm telling you as a
girl
i think they might not tell you all
right so
i don't know i mean but the people who
my partners who have seen me in
situations and seen perhaps an
aggressive side or yeah you know
masculine side if you have it does
depend on the type of crying like you
said if a guy is like blubbering or
whatever right usually silent crying is
what i do yeah i've never been
hysterical yeah but if it's just i feel
like crying is i feel like crying is
natural you know what we're all humans
yeah i'm not saying never cry but i'm
saying the more you do like again women
just aren't attracted to it so it's bad
i just think it's better to tell guys to
be more in control of their emotions
rather than to be emotionally available
right he doesn't know how to control his
emotions just be stone cold you know
what i'm saying okay
it's a thing what if he doesn't know how
to control his emotions well then he
should die
i mean he could he could either a go
through life not being able to control
his emotions or b learn how to control
your emotions take some classes i'm
pretty sure there's that you know
great advice
i was i was going to say like you see
little kids
boys and girls like they cried probably
just as much as each other
when
when boys get like a certain age
i don't know like just before puberty
like 10 11
12 they stop crying
whereas girls they'll carry on crying
i don't know if that's like uh it was
not like you know what it was
interesting i had nine siblings i like
disagree with you growing up my the
girls cried more than the guys you think
now i think like when little kids are
boys quite just as much as girls
it's when they cry they fall they cry
there's a parent turn a blind eye and
they're like okay they're fine what i
noticed with boys they get more they get
more aggressive and women like get more
like kids like like the boys would start
like kicking and screaming where the
girls would just start like crying
that's that's what i noticed i have nine
siblings so it was five boys and five
girls
yeah but i think it comes from an early
age of a boy saying yeah even like
because i worked in a primary school as
a pe teacher they say like uh man up or
like it
yes it's like children to
young boys from an early age
you're not supposed to cry but i think
i think also has to do with the
environment they grow up because a lot
of children are growing up with just one
parent yeah so if it's um you know a boy
and growing up with his mother
um she's probably gonna tell him you're
the man of the house you know man up
don't cry don't do this don't do that
you have to now you know take the
responsibilities of the house
so um yeah that's why like a lot of guys
then think that's not okay to cry it's
not okay to be emotional or you know
yeah just show that to women
i go ahead no i was going to say here
because
well in my household when i was younger
i didn't have a father figure but my um
mum's
sister's husband ex-husband sorry um he
kind of like stepped in and took that
role and like um from a very young age
like
obviously he was because i'm from europe
and like generally was like raised to be
like tough you know and all that stuff
and then like it got to a point where
it's like he
well he was like listen stop stopping
basically stop being a [ __ ] and then
like you know when your mom like when
you do something wrong when you break
side and your mum like beat you with a
body it got to a point where it's like
i'm firm and i'm just i'm i'm just
crying because it doesn't hurt it's just
like i'm just firming it like at one
point i started laughing at my wife
so she
i never got beaten from like 13 12 13
after after that i was like
i just think like it's more honest to to
guys like the world doesn't view you the
same as they do women you have to be
more in control of your emotions as a
guy
it's not like a fun reality i just think
you're kind of you're kind of lying to
guys if you don't tell them that
i'm not saying never cry and never get
emotional but you have to be more
emotional than what are more more stoic
than women
do you guys disagree with that
no that's [ __ ] as [ __ ]
that's just the way society is yeah
that's just the way
the world is like like you were saying
women
more attracted to guys who don't cry and
like
if you're
if you don't cry or show emotion you're
seen as stronger
more capable things like that
so it's a lot of things
but i must say i must say like
i think it should be okay for you to go
to your
male friends and be able to talk
because i know it seems like oh why are
you crying
but
like to help you guys within yourselves
and what you're doing and how you're
feeling that should be okay because i
know i can turn around go to my girl and
be like there's an issue
you know and it's it's kind of dealt
with it but as but as but but they see
that's the difference because like when
you go to your your friends of color you
can talk about it you talk about
everything you like you talk about guys
the guys that you slept with the size of
the whatever do you talk about
everything
that's a fact
if i look i'll put you this way right if
like i'll put it to this way my friend
just went through surgery right right
foot surgery right and instead of me as
a guy right he came up with like listen
i'm going through this i'll be like yeah
i shut up you crippled that's that's the
response that we get like oh you know i
busted his ass because i know he would
do exactly the same for me but that's
just the way we guys talk if he shows
emotion to me that's just like getting
puned joked about
you're you know that's that's but that's
just us guys we can't just talk about it
if it's like something serious like yo
my bro we're meeting at this location
come alone so i think then it's a
serious conversation but if it's like
we're talking about it and my guy goes
like hey yo bro like
man's going through the shut up man go
let's go you know i mean
no one's trying to hear that yeah but
that's that's the point though
like
you should be able to kind of come to
grounds to be able to talk about certain
things you're going for instead of
dealing with everything on your own
because it does get daunting and it does
build up over time and that might have
an effect on how you live life going
forward do you think
yeah
on that point yeah
obviously
i was gonna say yeah like i thought i
was gonna say no
like you know you've got good friends
around you when you're like good male
friends when you're allowed to talk
about
deep stuff and that but like
when you
i think you said like you should be able
to cry i don't like if you're
if you're a guy now in a relationship
you're more
likely to cry in front of your
girlfriend rather than go to your boys
talk about the problem and start crying
like i don't think that's
that i don't know i've never experienced
i've never seen any of my boys cry
like
talking about a deep issue we've talked
about deep issues and stuff like that
you should be able to yeah yeah i've
done that but like
like going up to them and like crying
like i feel like that would be even
worse than crying in front of your girl
100 in front of the man i'm like that's
i think because men
not a lot of men but just generally men
like the um emotional maturity or
capability to be able to
respond to a male crime maybe because
they don't it's like it's like a vicious
cycle because maybe because they don't
christ are therefore their friends
crying so it's it will be hard to
communicate to to be able to sort of
tend to him and
just basically like you got it
it's just like
for a man to cry for them it's just kind
of like more or less like sign of like
weakness basically like but that's not
that's not like in a way like oh i'm
crying about like my girl problems just
like in general like if you have a group
of friends right and then you're you're
normally chilling everyone's like doing
their own thing and then like one of
your friends comes up to you starts like
pouring his eyes out that group like as
a as as a guy group like that's be that
like that i got my [ __ ] like
this like we need to you know i don't
think most men
if that happened like
most men wouldn't know how to how to
react yeah like raw man's just like he's
just
burst out crying like what are you gonna
do like
but i feel like it also has to do with
like how long you've known your guys
yeah because if you've known them for
like six seven eight years they've been
there with you through the ups and downs
whereas if you've known them for like i
don't know a year they're probably going
to look at you sideways i was going to
say if it's your if it's your close
friend even if it's a big group whether
it's one guy or ten guys if they're your
close friends and you're crying they are
gonna feel it they're not gonna they're
gonna they're not gonna call you soft
because you're close you know you have a
bond it's like a brotherhood in general
they like to roast each other they like
to make fun of each other so like that
might be like it might be okay in the
beginning but once i feel like once you
realize that it's actually bothering
this person that you care about 100 yeah
that's when you show you know just
respect it yeah yeah that's true you
guys i'm going to read some more super
chats real quick um davon jackson i
express i expressed to my girl in a calm
matter how i was feeling since i was
feeling like i wasn't respected and that
i was used she kept belittling my
feelings we haven't talked in three
months now
um info vader do you think do you think
emotional reactions to these topics and
your behaviors to them align because
often today they're the opposite i think
emotional in your behaviors
i don't understand like my emotion
emotional reaction to what
you get
do you think do you
do you think emotional reactions to
these topics and your behaviors to them
align because often
today they're oh they're saying like
because you guys say one thing like that
you like even though you say you like
emotional guys like you probably don't
that's his point
i like what i like
yeah um okay carl solutions i disagree
bro i think many men commit suicide
because they're not taught to be strong
the suicide rate is going up as men are
becoming more feminized fifty dollars
from centipede damn i guess i gotta
represent though thank you 50.
okay i like it
um okay also guys this is the most
people i've ever had on a live we had
400 people earlier which is crazy 400 no
way let's
[Applause]
guys don't forget to like the video um
try i don't know if it's at i can't see
on my phone but i if we haven't hit a
hundred likes try to get to 100 or one
second and we love and appreciate it
um okay the conversation doesn't make
sense the conflation between being a
pushover and a nice guy as well as
conflating being emotionally available
being and being emotionally unstable um
51 from ninja watcher for life sentience
[Applause]
[Music]
has done gone i got me in my feelings ha
ha
um
oh my manager just turned on only
subscribers so you can only comment if
you've subscribed
[Laughter]
no more
that was that wasn't me but that was a
good move kobe thank you um okay on each
show please have everyone speak up and
into the mic clearly it shows lack of
care for the topic at hand and
disrespected the host guys okay today we
had a soundboard break so we're kind of
struggling um that's another thing
i got a soundboard off of facebook
marketplace and i immediately regret it
now because it broke unreliable wrong
so i have to buy another sun money
oh wait i forgot i actually forgot
that's another expense never buy it uh
she meant that with a please and i think
that 500 is going towards another
soundboard
okay um okay five five dollars from
chaos 29 muffin i'm on oh wait i read
that one sorry okay next one
um
uh go down okay um i'm a potato bruce
lee said
emotion can be your an enemy if you give
into your emotion you lose yourself be
at one with the emotion because the mind
the body
wait hold on
as emotion can be your enemy if you give
into emotion you lose yourself be at one
with emotion because the body always
follows the mind okay
50 pounds from d19 economy men cry less
because because it is not a good
strategy for them a man crying will get
a little empathy help from people from
women men as such a man will get help
more likely when he comes from a
position of strength i love that okay
wait also fifty dollars
[Applause]
okay um thank you guys so much again 400
people in the chat um let me see how
many likes we have hold on
um guys
get oh 229 likes can we get 300 can we
get this let's get it
okay um
okay do you guys think
um
so then
oh did you guys hear though i forgot to
say this earlier with the johnny depp
case
did you hear that she pooped in his bed
and she blamed it on the dog
you're lying down she did no she needs
to go prison just for that psycho alert
no that's actually really nasty well why
would you think it's okay to do that
like what in does it there's clearly
something not okay okay there in that
whole situation for you now to go and
put your
waist on someone's bed
because sunset sunset i like that
you're doing too much
from a guy's point of view why don't you
think have you ever had any men in a
toxic relationship where they don't
leave and why don't you think they leave
control
um
yeah
i think it just boils down to control
um 100 because of
i know a few friends who've been who've
been the aggressor in relationships and
there's literally no reason why you're
there because you're never home you're
cheating on your partner you're being
your partner you're beating your kids
but you you stay because you want you
just want control i feel like it's down
to control
um you want control what do you mean so
so the girl was beating him or the other
no no the other way around so the guy
was the aggressor okay the guy was the
aggressor and she stayed because she
wants control oh why the lady well why
the woman stands yeah like
i'm not like have you ever had a guy
friend that that's happened to you oh
okay
because johnny depp was in a
relationship with her for like years
this was going on
so i'm just curious if you have any male
friends maybe not to that extent but
something like that's happened too no no
i mean i've been well my lost ex was
pretty like all relations was pretty
toxic i don't have i don't know if i
have any friends that have been in a
relationship
um well
toxic was like
i didn't want to like it got so bad to a
point where like i didn't want to want
to be seen in like public with her
because it's like i go to no no it
really got that bad because what
happened was when we first started
dating it was sweet you know the
honeymoon stage and it was like so funny
sunshine and giggles that's how she got
me
um and then we got to like we got
together and she um we used to go to my
like a local bar and you know just hang
out after work you know just catch up
and stuff like that and she and then
after it got so bad to a point where
like she's like started screaming
arguing in public like i understand one
thing at home and like it's one thing
right but like when i have to look right
around
when she's going to the bathroom or
she's going to order a drink or
something and people are turning around
with like
like one of those is it's bad and then i
tried to explain it to her but she's in
her little world like oh no no no no and
i was listening there was a camera next
to you and i showed you that how many
people like you know i mean and for
example like if you keep you disappear i
told you this straight up if you keep
this up right one of these days we're
gonna be walking down the street right
you're gonna give some smirky guy or
some smoke so some girl like a look or
something i'll say something snarky
she's gonna slap you in the face you're
gonna be on the floor and i'm not gonna
help you i'm gonna look at the guy with
the girl but i listen you just proved my
point and shake his hand and keep it
stepping right because honestly like it
got really bad like it's this is it it's
a point when then
we broke up but i broke it off with her
like after like seriously because i was
the type of i was an optimist thinking
that like she might change
like you know keep dragging i dragged
out for 11 months i dragged it out were
you trying to fix her
no i want to say fix her just like
give her helpful advice
no no you know what yeah [ __ ] that she's
my activity yes i was trying to fix her
because the [ __ ] was crazy
i'm sorry the [ __ ] was crazy
like we couldn't go 15 minutes without
having an argument put it that way like
it was bad
but i think it might also be that hope
that the person might change yeah and
also like emotional dependency on the
person and complacency like once you're
so used to someone and then they kind of
act up i feel like you're more okay with
staying and tolerating it than just
instantly leaving i'm not gonna lie i
told people if she gets how many was it
30
40 or 50 subs i'll get i'll get my ex on
the show and then
yeah
so guys listen did you say thirty
thousand i said no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
50 or 60 by the end of next month yeah
i'll try getting my ex on the show so
guys yeah if you subscribe hit the
subscribe button right now oh yeah 50
000. no 50 to 60 50 or 60. we'll discuss
it on camera
we'll go 60 yeah i'm i'm the one getting
roasted here 60 000 subs he'll bring his
toxic acts on the show and i'll
interview them ask her why she was so
crazy
i'll be like
be like why were you insane
just just or not honestly but i just
blunt it out like yeah what's wrong with
you
what if she what if she says you were
the problem
okay cool
no that's exactly what she's gonna say i
know her because everything everything
she everything that i've done for her or
anything any problems that i wrote
should blame me
like she got so bad like you literally
you know like in front of your parents
right like if you swear to your parents
you'll get like a backhander something
like you know i mean i don't sweat in
front of my parents we went and had a
beach day lovely beach day we you know
we'll come back on the train and if she
didn't like we was having a conversation
she would disagree she started swearing
from eight in front of my mom and my
grandma brother like you don't do that
thing like like read the room yeah it
was bad
so yeah 66 60 000 subs guys
i might hit that soon
you know what if you listen if you do
cool i'm gonna hear her up on something
like you do but i think it's like listen
i'll reach out if she wants to come and
do the show that's fine if you don't you
can't blame me i tried
okay
um what about you any stories yeah i was
gonna say like i've seen situations
where like
the girls like you say that you say the
guy's whipped because he's like
oh yeah yeah come out let's like link up
and do something he said nah i can't
cause i'm with my goal and that and like
he's just like the girl's like not being
like controlling but like
she's like bet she's like rude to him
and stuff like
and like he's just taking it i feel like
yeah
that's that's a situation where i've
seen like a toxic relationship
but like
i feel like people stay in certain toxic
relationships because they've got like
that if you've got a child now it's like
you you've got to try and make it work
or more
if you get married quick let's say
you've only noticed about two years you
get married you've got to sort of stay
of that person or now you live together
it's like you
when you've got other things alongside
the relationships that are
you can't just
you can't just drop the relationship now
because it me it's not just you two
liking each other
like it's deeper than that so
like that's why they stay so you think
it's like they're in too deep like they
don't really know she's crazy and then
they get in so deeply
at first at first ever
sorry at first every relationship's good
like
at the start
every you wouldn't be in the
relationship if it was if you saw the
red flag straight away or if you like
if you didn't enjoy it at first you're
not going to be in that relationship so
it always the first part of the
relationship is always the best because
you're getting to know each other you're
having the most fun you're trying to
like impress each other
and then as it goes on that's when the
problems you'll see like the red flags
more clearly and you'll
you'll like that's when the problems
start occurring yeah that no no one's a
if if if you jump into a relationship
and the guy slaps you on the first date
are you gonna marry this guy you're not
so
he's gonna be really friendly and then
he's gonna be more possessive and it's
gonna it's gonna gradually increase to
him being abusive or whatever that's why
but do you think that comes with like an
insecurity like he doesn't want no one
else to have you or any type of thing
because control does have a big effect
on a relationship whether it's like a
small scale or not and it's like how do
you see that from the start like how do
you kind of gauge those kind of red
flags from the beginning like it's
really hard i was gonna say um has uh
it's probably an old tv program it's
based on a true event right have you
ever seen uh murdered by my boyfriend
yeah so yeah that's crazy yeah
so basically for
you guys have you seen it um
some people haven't seen it basically in
another show
so the girl starts dating this guy
everything everything goes good you have
a kid but then after that you know he
starts like
possessive possessive wouldn't let her
out the house and then he get he goes
and gets another girlfriend
while he's with her and the kid she goes
to um
to find out where she lives next thing
you know he goes into a store where she
works
black and blue differently and then yeah
man like so that's probably like the
perfect program to describe
like it's sad because it starts off
great and it ends up with him killing
her with a ironing board
[Music]
based on true story wow
there's a song there's a song similar to
that have you heard uh leslie by dave
talks about like domestic violence that
he just talks about like how the girl it
was all perfect like rainbow sunshine
and then it's just like it's a gradual
thing it's not suddenly he just attacks
you out of nowhere psych
it's like don't ignore the reds yeah
yeah don't ignore the little signs like
yeah you just can't
because at the end of the day everybody
has the right to leave
you know do you do you get what do you
think is worse being physically abused
or emotionally abused i always say
emotionally abused
both of them together at the same time
scars will heal scar emotion is called
that's for life
yes
i always say i would rather someone slap
me
than to say something that would happen
for the rest of my life because i
exactly you want to repeat
in relationships play fighting is like
very dangerous because if a guy gets too
comfortable even a girl gets too
comfortable like with hitting you
um then suddenly when they actually do
hit you once they're mad they don't see
it as that bad yeah like what happened
to me in my past relationship like the
guy used to just like hit me for fun
like play fighting in the beginning i
was kind of like whoa like but then it
got like more and more and more and i
would have like bruises on my arms and
[ __ ] he would grab me as well and he
would just see it as oh no it's just i'm
just playing with you i'm like bro
don't you see my arms especially because
my skin is lighter right so you can
really see it so what why did what was
why when she'd like leave then why don't
you you know i mean
because i was dumb like listen i was in
in that relationship i feel like i was
in a way like emotionally dependent on
him and he manipulated me to the point
where i was actually there while he was
doing the craziness
and i was still there like the tip of
the iceberg was when we had broken up
and we hadn't been together for probably
like eight months
and he came to my house and he just
smashed my door like i had a huge hole
in my door because you heard a guy
inside my house i was on facetime with a
guy
he smashed my door
crazy
and he thought he didn't think of it as
bad because the next
the next thing he came with crazy
that was my next question do you think
um abusers like test the water
and like they start kind of like start
they kind of start to see like what
they're capable of they they tip their
toe in a little bit you know
i feel like a lot of them are smart as
well they're like um
yeah they're like really manipulative
and like make you feel like it's your
fault or
what they're doing is fine and you're
they're the victim even like
they'll make you look crazy yeah like
they'll
they'll be nice to all of your friends
like
like
they're not they're not just they're not
idiots they're like they actually can be
smart people the way they they're so
controlling and yeah
stuff here but i just think you have to
be smart if that's what you want to do
you can't
like just like you said on the first
date you can't just go there and just
slap someone because you know that's out
of order but within time you know like i
might just grab her and do this all
right i can get away with that like it's
a thing where
back to my point like you just can't
ignore red flags like if you feel if you
feel some type of way uncomfortable on
one little thing you have to note that
in your head like oh that happened i'm
not cool with it so yeah but i'm not
gonna lie we've all ignored red flags
before and we always hope for the better
but so i don't think anybody can say
like don't ignore red flags or like
because we've all done it well we've all
ignored it the problem is especially as
women were attracted to red flags
because the same thing that make the
same thing that makes a guy like toxic
makes him attractive
so like for example cheating right have
you ever have you guys ever stayed with
a cheater no
good for you
really no that's really rare usually
usually one girl will say yes
but like the reason a lot of times girls
do right is because that's a sign of
pre-selection
so like girls want a guy that other girl
girls want
and like the same thing with like like
abuse on some level like like even
though the
i mean we're not attracted to obviously
them like beating our ass like clearly
not but
a guy that has aggression in him like
women are attracted to a guy that can
protect you and it's the same traits
that make the guy the villain make him
the hero but also like the like being
controlling with a girl because in some
cultures like latino culture for example
is seeing not like the crazy control but
like him caring and controlling you a
little bit is seen as like
something you would want
because he's showing you that he cares
but then obviously he can go into the
toxic controlling and it goes further
and further and further yeah
girls like it when a guy's a little bit
controlling like if he's like come in
now they're like oh like
it's weird
like they like getting like not like
obviously hit like obviously like
physical stuff during like
intimacy like getting slapped in that so
it's like it's true but yeah some girls
like that though some girls lagging
spanx you know getting a little choked
out pulled hair you know i mean like
what i've asked girls this question
before like what's more attractive babe
can you please be quiet or shut the [ __ ]
up
i've said this i've said this on pretty
much i think i've said it on pretty much
every podcast like girls like the guy
that's like if you're going off here and
like yo just and you'll be like listen
hey shut the [ __ ] up breath like and
you'd be and then you always be like
damn like you just put me in my place
it's not fun i don't like that i like it
i'm not okay with it you're not okay
with it
put your foot down but like deetana i'm
like whoa like nah but i know people
okay i'm putting a scenario you're you
okay so he's done something wrong right
you're snapping on him like you're going
like you're trying to be the alpha right
now like you're trying to wear the pants
right and he just told you hey listen
like he just shows you like no you need
to shut the [ __ ] up but he showed you
like in a way where it's like damn like
he put me in my place
[Laughter]
have you ever have you ever had a guy
kick you out like you need to get the
[ __ ] out
no no no no
i've heard girls say like that's like
the most attractive thing of a guy
you're there to stay alive
they don't want to kick me but guys guys
you know you know you're dead
you know what's funny that's not
emotionally available you know what's
emotionally available saying babe that
bothered me you know it's not
emotionally available baby shut the [ __ ]
up
i don't like that we like this
okay i'm gonna read some super chats um
uh okay we're ready a long applause a
hundred dollars
oh my gosh okay guys guys i bought a
soundboard off of facebook marketplace
it went poorly i really appreciate these
um and a new camera that's this is going
for um don't forget to like the video
while you're here let's see how many
likes we're at we're at
um
let's see 284 likes can we get to 300
can we get to 300 i think we can
okay let me go up oh no guys
oh my gosh wait okay
okay okay i thought i lost the super
chats because it loaded
um okay 20 super chat from i'm a potato
that is a good username with them an x
10 years i was with an ex for 10 years a
new woman friends
then cut
a new girlfriend a new woman friend like
maybe a girl came in then the cops are
at my door she said i threw her down the
next protection order was kicked out of
my house three months until the court
date pushed back six more months until i
was proven innocent no punishment to her
oh so she accused him of abuse basically
and he had to wait nine months for the
trial i feel for you bro
and there was no like she even though
she falsely accused him because and she
couldn't like prove it yeah
then like he he still lost he was in his
house for nine months yeah i think the
the the fact that
he lost time as well it's kind of peak
can't just not on our
the sun is gonna be up regardless you
know i mean yeah oh my gosh you know
what i've heard about like child i've
heard that in child custody cases
where the woman like won't let the man
see the kids and the guy has to wait to
take her to court and then he hasn't
seen his kid for six months and then
they go to court and they're like when's
the last time you saw your kid
and he's like six months ago
but it's because of
and so it almost puts them
like but it's interesting because even
in that case i don't know how
because you don't want
because some girls just can't prove they
were abused
you know what i'm saying like it's not
like every girl falsely accuses them
especially when it's like emotional or
like yeah
then
financially and plus in like some case
in some like like you said in some child
cases like a lot of well
i don't know what the percentage is but
like it's always favors the woman so
like the man hardly ever wins like to
keep the child even like even if he
wants to you know i mean like it's it's
hardly it's hardly like oh
sorry the court normally favors the
woman to take care of the child because
i don't know for a reason but like
that's that's how it goes
and you know i've heard and i i haven't
actually read this study myself so i
don't know if i'm misquoting it but i've
heard that after the age of like seven
men are actually better with kids
because they're more like logical so
it's more structured for the kid where
women like feel different every day but
it's like below the age of seven women
are better with the kids
does that go down to like nurturing
because you know women are natural
nurtures
that kind of thing but
i could see
why kind of yeah but when the baby says
the words are daddy even though you're
the one taking care of it that must hurt
that must hurt
like you did all of that for like nine
months and the first word to come out is
that dad
you're holding l's y'all holding it
oh my god i didn't even think about that
you know what's crazy too johnny depp
had his finger severed
by her like she threw a bottle at him
and his finger was severed off like it
came out it's actually like physical
damage
but still
that's that's nice you did that
this is right
imagine if he imagine if he hit her back
like the whole narrative would have been
he hit her
but i i think he should have like do you
guys think he should have hit her back
swing yes or no
you broke me
what do you guys think in that situation
could he have hit her back probably
would yeah i'm fine
i'll be swinging i'm sorry that's like
like you said life and death situation
someone throwing buttons at me yeah
absolutely i think regardless it just
shows how much strength he has mentally
because you always say i would hit it
back he didn't yeah that shows how calm
he is
like that's a lot of strength mentally
i think he embraced jack sparrow but too
much he's always like
yeah like you don't know
we don't really know what happened prior
to that so
she
the abuse before that
now it's kind of normal to me it's not
like us hearing that that shocking like
his fingers come off but
he's been abused obviously prior to that
so it's like
he's sort of used to it and it's like
you get you get numb to it i guess
like your threshold of what was normal
changes
what do you guys think could he hit her
back
i think he could swing for her a little
bit
humbly
humble you've literally broken a part of
me now like like a humble little writer
that would like to deliver
no no no no one would actually know what
they'd do unless they was in that
situation
but i felt like if it was me
like that's my
i think i would just i would want to
leave
but yeah i don't know i'm not doing i'd
have to be in that situation to know she
would she would hold a humble two-piece
i'm not gonna lie to you yeah that's
crazy
yeah
she's trying to kill you like
do you think that women like test men
sometimes to see what they can get away
with hundred percent
yes a hundred percent yes like it's at
the beginning of the distinction
that the man needs to set the precedence
and be like that is not acceptable and
depending on how he responds to that
will determine how she respects from the
season for the duration of the
relationship it happened to me once what
happened it was it wasn't tell me the
story it was
nothing tell us
we're having a debate and it turned into
an argument and as she was storming off
she pushed my head which is nothing it's
literally nothing
but i saw red and i think it was the way
i could
i spoke to her because i have quite an
explosive um
disposal personality whenever i'm angry
i'm quite calm i've got a high tolerance
so when it when it peaks it just it's an
explosion so when
even though it was just a push to the
head i could have spoken to her but i i
literally exploded and i think at that
point
she's referenced that moment like
numerous amount of time that she
wouldn't there's a line that she knows
she can't cross so i feel like it's
important for men in those situations or
and women to set boundaries from very
very early on
yeah
yeah i i agree with the early boundaries
100
boundaries yeah
do you think his girls are we aware
that we're trying to test them
i'm not talking like just in a normal
relationship i'm not talking abusive but
there's like little things you know
little things like what like um like
they call it in the manosphere they'll
call it like [ __ ] tests
and like pick up so they're kind of like
girls test you to see how you respond to
see like if you're truly like masculine
and dominant
like if you don't tell me off for making
you wait 30 minutes yeah
that's one of them actually
that would be a bad test for me because
i so as i said i have a high tolerance
so if that was a test for me i'd fail it
because i'm very patient so if that's
your measuring stick yeah and you keep
doing that eventually i'm going to
explode and you will know that that's
not you know what i'm trying to say with
something physical i'm going to respond
immediately but if it's what if it's
making me wait 30 minutes i'm a very
patient person but eventually when i
address it it's going to be with some
sort of rage i think if someone made me
wait 30 minutes like i'll let them know
it's not cool because think about it now
like what if our son is at school 30
minutes wait
no i see but that's
the whole patience thing because i'm a
very punctual guy like if if you if you
tell me be there a certain time i'll be
there like half an hour earlier out just
so i know because like you know god
forbid it happens you know just be
punctual type thing i mean and then like
obviously i've got friends and all that
like
other people like a girlfriend
girlfriend friends um
that'd be like they take their sweet
time
like
and it's it's one of those things where
it's like bro like
listen yeah you but you're different you
you get it like not a lot of women do
that that's the thing
like you get it like you know what i
mean be there exactly oh actually no
truth be told you you always looked out
the house you
you couldn't leave so you wasn't there
two times if you went to boots yeah
okay look at it yeah i don't have it i
don't have a wallet now
no that's forgiving that's forgiven
that's forgiven but it's just like some
people just like just it's not hard like
for example like you know black man's
time the whole the whole thing right
where if i'm like you know there's
there's there is a there's a thing about
being fashionably late
to a party and then and then yeah this
show you're trying to come in halfway
through you know who you are huh
the guy that was rigging the doorbell
i'm like we're in the middle of the show
now we are in the middle of the show my
brother the time there to be there was
nine o'clock 9 30 start i'm sorry but
you did not make the cuts unfortunately
you have been cut off
no hard feelings don't know how feelings
no but like it's almost like though if
you if you do that with girls and you
like they're going to test you to get
you i don't get why why would you why
what's the point of that i don't get
that you're just testing i don't think
it's conscious a lot of the time so
you're so you turn up late intentionally
well i know i'm i'm i'm punctual i'm
gonna be honest
my mom taught me punctuality
intentionally yeah but why like why
would you do that because everything's
attached to them it's like no because
it's like they want to see how much of a
man you are like they want to see if you
are can you hold boundaries yeah can you
are you like are you the type like are
you going to protect your piece protect
your space are you a strong are you a
strong guy there was there was my friend
right who just passed his license right
so he um he got his car and all that
stuff he had a girlfriend she lives um
outside of london not too sure where she
lives but basically she lives in my my
area she lives like
30 35 minutes basically she can take a
bus to get to his right
but then i feel like she just kept like
testing whether he's going to compete
like you know pick her up pick her all
the time yeah yeah so and obviously like
he done it like i saw he was like the
start of relation but now it's just like
i i feel like i feel like he had to yeah
he had to you know be like listen yo i'm
i'm okay with you picking you up that's
not a problem
but like you gotta like make
a trip every now and then you know
honestly it's very attractive when a guy
comes oh yeah opens the door for you
closes walks around yeah
yeah it's very attractive when the guy
is like listen be ready yet i don't know
7 p.m i'm coming to pick you up yeah you
know what was it attractive gas prices
okay
actually no that's so true the worst is
like when a guy asks you like what like
what are you yeah like they want you to
plan the day girls like to know exactly
what's gonna happen at this time this
time who's gonna be there what i'm going
to wear
how many more questions do you want
i just yeah i just want you to say hey i
found this good spot let's go there i'm
going to pick you up at this time now
where do you where do you want to go
what do you want to do
but the more it goes on like if that
continues
and he's always picking the places i
mean it's fine but communication comes
in what we're talking about with like
first times like first oh yeah yeah yeah
but let's say let's say it's been like
six months down he's still doing that
but no i kind of like that because it
takes the pressure off of me it's one
thing like it's one that it's one thing
if he says we can't go anywhere else
like i'll tell him if i if there's
somewhere i really want to try but it's
nice to have a guy make decisions i'm
not we're not decisive beings we like it
when you guys do it exactly like don't
tell me oh we'll figure it out no
tell me where we're going yeah yeah fair
enough you're sure about it what do you
what do you want to do like you asked me
out exactly why are you asking me
i feel like yeah if a guy if a guy
genuinely likes you yeah this is where a
girl can see it early
if a guy actually likes you you you
he'll want to take you out on a date
yeah you think of things but
imagine how many girls this guy's
talking to he's not going to take every
single one of them like he's not like he
might be rich i don't know but he's not
got that much time or whatever so he's
going to be like ah trying to try to get
out like what are you on basically like
you would be surprised how many guys
have that much time
different girls you
that's the bums they have a lot of free
they always get the most game though i'm
not even gonna think
they got a lot of time to like learn how
to talk
no you know what it is i'll say like for
example me i've said this i've said this
in a podcast before um like i'm an
active person right
and i don't mind planning like i've
never minded planning a day so like you
know the where the how the when and all
that stuff but like different girls are
for different vibes in it like you know
i mean like different girls like
different things you know so like i'm a
quite an active person so for me a date
a first date second or whatever just i
any type of date has to include
something like
fun and activity you know i mean so we
can both like you know
bond i'd say you know talk born and
stuff like that so it's not just like oh
let's just go get some food and like
talk you know i mean that's
dated that's dating active dates are the
best ones
i need to know how competitive you are
almost
as a guy do you let the girl win no no
no what no no i always say this every
time like okay cool i may not win but i
will still give you still whole time
you will still feel it if you if you
beat the guy is that unattractive that
that could give you like the ick or
something
but you know it's not enough because no
no because you be no you say that's
unattractive yet but you'd be like like
you you keep trying to say something to
me like shut up man i beat you don't do
that don't talk don't have a chat okay
cool let's let's say you go let's say
you go bowling now on a date yeah and he
tries to throw it and he falls or
something like and he's just bad that he
can't ball he gets like zero and then
you you like your decent eye level yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly like
straight away take me off i swear
like i'm not good at it
imagine he's really bad like yeah but
imagine if i was really bad and he's
looking at me like
like
a guy's not going to really look at he's
got he didn't really care if she's bad
at golf i don't care like i find that
you know like he's like i find that you
know what here you know what he's got
golf here is actually a really good
example you know because for girls bad
yeah that just invites the man to get
touchy feely and show her how it's done
you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying that bro you'd
be like oh she she'd be trying to swing
she's missing the baby let me show you
and i'm saying you get your hips slower
how many days you've been on twitter
you know what i enjoy doing i enjoy
beating guys at basketball that's my
thing because i enjoy beating guys at
basketball because i'm actually good
it's true like we i went to one
scrimmage with her right
and but it's on youtube but we in that
youtube video we was made look bad right
but in the actual game right yeah we
have not we want we walked in that game
we did not lose one game i just keep
giving her the ball and she was bullying
people inside these boys oh my gosh
no but they edited it out they edited
they had a youtube video and they filmed
me posting up on these guys and killing
them and they edited all of that out and
only put the shots i missed sounds so
irritated that's a vital i was i was
bodying these boys
we got to go around two though for real
yeah i know we gotta go back
okay i'm gonna read some super chats
okay eat godly two dollars hit her back
with a fist full of pearls that's close
shoot your shot my boy shoot your shot
that's clever again guys all donations
are going towards another sound board
because mine broke today and another
camera and remember we have until the
end of the month to raise this money so
every donation is appreciated so
um okay and then the next
super chat is 35 czar
what is a czar and you know car
um if if girls like tall guys then don't
tall men ruin their genes by dating a
short girl should a rich guy date a tall
attractive girl for his son's sake i'm
going to say yes because i'm 5 11 and a
half
i've seen two short people have a two
kids
no i love it i love my both my parents
both my parents are like way smaller
than me
i'm taller than both my parents too yeah
they're like the same height though you
could get your jeans i feel like i was
adopted because my parents were all
short
i'm not gonna lie to you
bro like if you've seen my mom like
she's shorter than you
she's shorter is she short of me
like
i don't even know i don't know the exact
height but she's actually quite short is
she like shorter than five five oh no
she's a bit above that
yeah no but like not my dad when i
wasn't all that you know that's what i
thought yeah
in your family then i am the one in the
family
yeah but the thing is like for me like a
perfect like for me to date right like
i've always described it like my golden
numbers for girls heights anywhere
between five five
and five nine that's like
would i with an exception obviously i
wouldn't say that i would not date you
know someone else that's taller but you
know why why
why five five and five nights actually
you can flip them like a pancake
i'm sorry like you can like you can
listen you don't understand like a short
a short girl yeah like if she's down to
you know yeah
well she's she's just easy to flip
actually
i'm sorry that's
me that's mine um okay
okay i'm one more super chat albert nato
retro women will take every opportunity
to dump dump on you if they do something
better within you that's when you know
she's no good look
don't blame me for being good at
basketball okay
look at it she's still hey she thinks
i'm uh she's a better shirt than me i do
i don't i don't think i could beat you
in one-on-one you're too tall you're too
tall i couldn't beat you in one-on-one
it's about the game like if you know the
game like you can weave around and stuff
no
that's the thing i i couldn't beat you
in one-on-one but i think i could beat
you and around the world
you're too tall for me to beat you in
one-on-one challenge accepted
okay um
i'm trying to think do you guys okay
kind of um
off topic question a little bit do you
guys think that paternity tests should
be mandatory
like at birth with kids
paternity well to find out who the
before yes oh yeah absolutely yeah
who's the daddy
yeah because imagine i need to know
yeah yeah
because imagine how many
like
imagine how many families there are when
like that's not actually their dad or
something like yeah
like it's probably more common than
people think it's good for clarity it's
good for next steps in life
because imagine you don't know you have
a kid out there or the kid you're
looking after is not yours that's my
like that's what jeremy kaushal is there
for
you know why
so you have you would have um doctor sue
or wherever the hell is
that fulfill whatever
i feel like women would get offended if
you're like not like i want a dna test
or something like they're gonna be like
what you think i've cheated or like well
yeah
but the thing is if you haven't cheated
then it should be no problem you should
you know
i just get over it
i feel like women would be like they'll
take that as like
what you think i'm cheating or like
yeah like not trusting
yeah but i definitely feel like it's
good for clarity do you think a woman
should be able to go to jail if she
has a guy raising someone else's kid so
let's say he spent five years raising a
kid that wasn't his was she aware of it
yes she knew oh
she knew and put him in that situation
because he spent five years of his life
raising the kids so shouldn't she spend
five years of her life in jail i think
joe's a baby
who's going to look after the kid then
you gotta find that job mom's
or if it's jail time maybe like a
three-month sentence or something
five years that's extremely i just well
i think having a guy raise someone
else's kid for five years is extreme but
i wouldn't say like jail time maybe just
have to repay him yeah like a [ __ ] yeah
but he can't get back his time
energy investment his emotional
investment looking after a kid for five
years and then go in jail for five years
like i feel like going to jail for five
years it's a lot worse okay let's let's
do one year
i don't think like joe was gonna like
what's that gonna so hit her with a huge
fine yeah
what if she can't pay it yeah well she
wants monthly installments is a thing
okay okay so what happens when you can't
pay where do they take you no but you
can pay in installments
you're somehow taking care of this child
so you're probably working
i just i just think moving forward
they should go to jail for it because i
think that women should know that like
you can't do that
like there's a difference between
there's a difference between being
afraid of a fine and being afraid of
literal jail time like do you don't you
think that would make women think twice
before doing it
i think yeah but just not that long yeah
i don't feel like joe's the right
the right punishment i feel like they
need to go on like a i don't know like a
course or something or of course
dr phil
is there a course that says don't sleep
with other people when you're in a
relationship
and pin it on them
like like ultimately taking away the mom
from the kid at the age of five or
whatever and putting her in jail for
five years huh that's hurting the kid as
well so i think like she said like just
paying installments like
fine or something but that still hurts
the kid because what if like yeah and
maybe but that's not as bad as going to
jail
right i guess i guess
i get where you're coming from because
if that was the case then nobody would
ever do that because of the
repercussions of being with your
children so it would be an effective
punishment because if as a mom if you
know you're not going to be with your
child if you do something something then
you're not going to you just never no
woman would ever do that well it just i
think my point more is whenever like i i
bring up a more extreme punishment for
women like it just seems like as a
society and usually when i have guests
they're like oh no don't do that
like but it doesn't seem like it's the
same for men
i just think when kids are involved in
something else
and like yeah but sometimes but men go
to jail for not paying child support
that happens
so why why don't women go to jail for
pinning a little like wasting years of a
man's life
that's a good point
but the the
the man he's gonna love that child
either way because
so that makes it worse although although
you're not like dna or whatever like you
you
you're
you're you're going to be with that
woman because she said that's your child
so you look so you love her and you love
that's your family like you can't i
don't know i feel like you're going to
have an emotional bond to that just
because someone says none that's not
your yeah but if you if you break up
you're not obligated to i mean you will
be but after
you're still going to be the child it
depends it's it's like it's like having
a friend that you've grew up with it's
like that's like your brother like you
feel like
you like that's your boy like but you're
not actually
um
you're not blood related just not dna
but yeah sometimes
your
friends or people that are not actually
related to you are closer than your
actual family itself yeah
yeah
yeah i mean so because you have a bond
with it the women shouldn't have
consequences or extreme consequences
because you bonded with the kid yeah i
still feel like it should have
consequences but like
i feel like most men if they was looking
after a child for five years they're not
gonna be like nah that's not my child
now
they're obviously at first they're gonna
be like what the hell maybe like not see
them for a couple months but i feel like
they're still gonna love like that
they've loved that child so it's gonna
be like what i'm saying is what if if
that's not your child then she cheated
on you so
most men are not gonna stay so if you're
not staying are you still raising the
child whilst not being in a relationship
like so you get complicated you wasted
five years taking care of this kid what
you're going to spend another like 13
that doesn't really make sense yeah
that's true and you're gonna put all
that your time energy resources into
what
so you've wasted all this time and it's
the same thing like men don't get oh
that's too extreme when they have to go
to jail for child support you don't see
people marching the streets for that
but a woman can literally pin
a guy
for years
and i i don't think there's any
punishment as far as i know
it's wrong
it is wrong it just seems like there's a
lack of like accountability for women in
society i don't i don't think there's a
good enough reason that's why the woman
would lie about that
lying about a kid being okay she may
have cheated yeah like the woman said
that's your son when it's not your son
like
why would like there's loads of cheese
he probably doesn't want the
relationship to break up yeah what if
he's paying the bill like if if a girl
is paying the bills and not really
attracted to god because that happens
like girls will marry a dude because he
can take care of her not because she's
actually attracted to her so then she
cheats with the guy she's actually
attracted to like physically yeah gets
the kid from him but takes the resources
from the other guy
the man wastes years of his life
finds out it's not his and there's no
punishment oh oh no that should be a
punishment
so he's essentially a sugar daddy folk
that kid basically i feel like yeah
jail time could be could be a case
that's crazy so like would you
would you then change your mind and say
maybe she should go to jail or do you
stand by it has to be a harsh
consequence because that's crazy doing
all that yeah
what do you think you guys change your
mind still jail no jail
lock her up lock her up
jail go around and if she's like
what's it called like not being um
remorseful or like
being forgiven like saying like no like
i don't know he deserved it or whatever
like i feel like yeah she needs to go to
jail
i think it doesn't matter if she's
remorseful if i steal from you it
doesn't matter if i say sorry i should
go to jail if you pin a kid on someone i
don't think it matters if you're
remorseful go you lock her up i think
the hard part for me is the kid cause i
wouldn't want to put a kid in a system
that fails kids all the time sending her
from home to home to home so do you
think they should when other people
commit crimes so like um
i had a cousin that was addicted to
drugs so he would always steal things
because he was addicted to drug
um now he
he didn't have a kid but let's say he
did
should the court take that into
accountability or into consideration oh
let's not send him to jail
because
i understand what you're saying
um but i feel like
if you're stealing and you're a drug
addict you're ultimately putting this
kid in danger anyways uh-huh
but if you just told someone which is
really bad as well that they're their
father you're not putting the kid in
that much danger yeah but you're
stealing time and resources
from another person so in in essence
like you could take the drug addict off
of it let's just say he was stealing
like it's the same thing you're just
stealing resources time and attack it's
almost worse actually to pin a kid
like i don't i just don't it shouldn't
matter if the person has a kid or not
it shouldn't matter like did they commit
the crime or did they not commit the
crime
like in my eyes that should be a crime
do you disagree with that
i don't disagree with being a crime i
disagree with the punishment of five
years of jail
um
not necessarily jail maybe like he said
like three months five months
but five years
um
that's long i just think it should be
equal for how long was he pinned how
long did you how many years did you
steal from him
but i get what you say when you say
stealing time because it is thrilling
time but you're also like out of this
like you have freedom of movement you're
like it's love this is a kid like you're
showing love in these five years but i
get where you're coming from but i don't
think it's the same as being in jail for
five years yeah but you're now you have
nothing so you go from showing love and
now you have no rights to that kid
she can she can kick you out you have no
right to see him you you you built
something for five years
for it to come out empty-handed but
that's something else though if she then
after those five years goes and says our
restraining order that's not your kid
that's something else
but if she continues to say like i want
you to be the father from now on like
yeah yeah
and that's completing something else
than saying restraining order well i
just i think it's like did you commit
what should be a crime or did you not i
don't think any of the circumstances
matter just like if you steal from
someone i don't think it should be oh
were they did they have a reason to
steal what was their mentality all this
stuff no it's like did you steal or did
you not steal
yeah
yeah i hear what you're saying but i
feel like with all crimes there's always
like
there's always a good and there's
there's a crime that you can commit
where there's could be a good reason to
actually do it
like obviously killing and stealing is
wrong as well but if i'm dying on the
street i'm gonna rob you for your
sandwich like yeah and like there's root
there's
but but in the eyes of the law they
don't yeah
i was gonna say as well in other
countries it's um
if you catch your wife cheating on you
you can you can actually be sentenced um
for time
um
i don't know what country is but yeah
but in certain countries if if your wife
cheats on you
or you catch her in the act then she can
be sentenced for time in
jail
um i have a bunch of super chats i'm
gonna read so
okay
this is actually a good point so men do
not get the privilege of paying
installments when it comes to child
support they will be jailed up and the
state is incentivized to do so look up
divorce inc movie if a woman knowingly
causes paternity fraud put her in jail
he was robbed
um tough love
[Music]
our future md the biggest tell that your
girl cheated is
if she gets kit if she gets upset about
a genetic test jail screws up kids but
having a felony with no jail times three
times the money is fine dna tests should
be mandatory
not step daddy season because that would
take away everything
yes
we're not out here to take over the
payments these days because honestly
like paternity tests like because would
you guys agree like going forward let's
say let's say going for like today they
decided to put a new law they said dna
tests are mandatory now you have the
opportunity if you've like done that to
a guy
like tell him now there's no you're not
going to be charged with anything but
going forward if you pull one over on it
like you will go to jail do you think
that's fair
absolutely
yeah
like
like you're talking from a perspective
like they're like like from this day
forward if you have something nothing
will happen if you say something now but
going off the day after that yeah i'd
say that's a fair point i'll say that
yeah they know the law and they're still
committing it then yeah yeah they know
what's going on consequences yeah
okay um another another fifty dollars
guys
you guys you're gonna get me a new
camera
uh okay paternity frog fraud is
malicious to the core a man is deceived
into investing his time effort money
emotions into a seed that is not his why
didn't the mother have that forethought
about her child when she lied ultimately
the man was robbed
five dollars from damien roberts
mandatory paternity testing at birth
even though or though if that
happened ex expect a large increase in
abortions to avoid accountability on the
part of the women involved
twenty dollars um i love from goose i
love how pearly has to paint the picture
for y'all to decide if jail is a
sufficient punishment
um fifty dollars
okay okay in the u.s courts are
hard-pressed um to
oh my gosh i'm sorry guys hard-pressed
to dis disestablish paternity because
someone will have to pay for the child
and the court wants its 66 kickback for
each child support payment until his
name is removed from the birth
certificate he is legally the father
oh my god that's crazy i did not know
that so a guy could have signed the
birth certificate and he will still have
to pay child support
even though he's not the father until
they legally change it and they're crazy
that's crazy that's wrong that's that's
right
no i mean i don't know if that's it's a
comment so i i check it but like if
that's true that's insane i did not know
that
um okay well i think this was actually a
really good show you guys are great um
i'm gonna actually close it on that so
why don't you guys go around um say any
closing thoughts and where people can
find you
um louisa j and that's l-o-u-i-s-a-j-a
underscore
with the e at the end of the day but
yeah um any closing thoughts uh
just stay safe
stay safe
just stay safe
my socials are shorty with the fro
that's s-h-o-r t-y
right here representing
s-h-o-r-t-y w-i-t-h-t-h-e-f-r-o
um and my closing thoughts are um i do
believe that it would be amazing if you
know paternity would be determined at
birth and it would also like you know um
help with the problem if it's true with
the um paternity being it would
basically solve that issue of the guy
having to pay child support
i've gotten this much
yeah
um follow me on socials instagram is
troy waters9
um twitter was nine underscore
um
play football
send me fresh new africa
[Applause]
yeah soon be on the big screen but yeah
um
yeah i thought
everyone's opinions and that was really
good so it was really good to um get
people's viewpoints and yeah and really
enjoyed it
my instagram is p-a-r-v-a
r-o-g-h-a
and i would just say be vulnerable
towards your partner and your friends
and just learn how to communicate
um
my instagram is david santos goggle of
chenko but i'm sure our beautiful host
will put it in the description
um
last thoughts i mean
just you know
i don't know no last to be honest man
the show was the show was really good
everyone's opinion was valid everyone
had interesting ideas to share so yeah
um my socials are well my instagram is
funny it's candy floss chocolate muffin
that's kind of cute
um there's candy with two eyes not away
it was great meeting everybody i think
everybody had great points it was very
interesting our conversation
um my takeaway i think um back to the
amber heard and johnny depp it's it's
understandable that we're naturally
biased towards women when they um
open up about abuse but i feel like we
should all take the time to understand
both sides of the story rather than
being quick to judge as hard as it is to
do so
okay well this was a really good show
thank you guys for all the super chats
you guys were awesome um
i think i feel like i had something to
say but i don't remember what it was
oh oh i do okay guys all i forgot to put
their instagrams in the description
today was kind of a rough day i'm going
to after the show but if you want to
follow them now go to my instagram which
is just.pearlythings they're all tagged
in my story so you can just like go to
my story and click on their instagrams
um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification about
guys seriously buy the meal plan if you
want to lose weight like i swear to god
this is the best meal plan ever and it
helps support the show if you buy the
meal plan so um that helps go towards
the camera we get